[Music]
[Applause]
here's sean salisbury former nfl
quarterback host of the sean salisbury
show on sports talk 790 in houston great
to have you on buddy how are you i'm
doing great you guys mentioned i was
getting a lot of laughs listening to you
guys and congratulations on the the all
of them going
uh you said you you may go down in
flames dan i could teach you guys how to
do that if you want
i i know how to do that and this tattoo
that says bench warmers right here on my
arm i got that too okay good to be on
with you man what role does ryan
tannehill play in helping malik willis
get better or what should he have said
in that situation well i i first of all
i don't know
why this is a national topic because i
know it's the offseason we're looking
and i'm glad to talk about this because
his role first off is to
overcome what he overcame last year and
get his butt back in there and play well
so he can help his team win
nowhere in the job description does it
tell ryan tannehill that your first
priority just like you dan when i came
to sp espn had no clue your job wasn't
to seek me out my job was to seek you
out learn how to interview and ask
questions when at a guest
so ryan taniel's job is to be great
leaders not only make themselves better
but more importantly they maximize other
people's ability and that includes
mentoring but
it is malik willis job
it is you know uh
ritter's job it was patrick mahomes job
to talk to the guy who'd been in the
league seek him out when i was in
minnesota warren boone didn't come to me
he asked if i need help but i went to
him and followed him around or steve
large at my rookie year because i wanted
to learn more so while he's got a job to
do and i'm quite sure that he'll say hey
man you want to come watch tape but if i
want to watch tape and do lonely work if
i'm malik willis and do it with him you
go up and say ryan man do you mind if i
watch tape with you i want to pick your
brain and it's not always what a mentor
says it's how he leads
and when you're on the field you can
learn a lot from a guy to watch how he
does his job instead of talk about how
he does his job i don't think for one
second it's his job title he's competing
i hope they get along in the room but
you want to beat each other's brains in
on the field it is malik willis
responsibility and any other young
quarterback or player to go to the guy
who's been there and chase him down and
have him help you that way and you do it
with open arms and i would imagine
tannehill would it's not tana hill's job
to chase malik willis down he's a third
round pick i don't even know why we're
discussing this not like he was the
second pick of the draft yeah i think
those are all great points and once
again they're valid points because
they're coming from your perspective
you've been there and you were there
with the hall of famer and warren moon
not that warren moon was threatened by
you but at all but
at all
um it was even less than what you're
saying that he was threatened by you
right but still
um we would have young anchors come into
sportscenter
and i it wasn't my job to go there and
give them a tutorial
i wasn't going to lose my job but if
they did ask for advice whether it was
rich eisen or
larry beale or stuart scott rhys davis
then i would give advice right and and
that's i that was it was more of watch
what we do how we do it how we prepare
and then follow along with that but i
think ryan tannehill realizes
his job is in jeopardy
a year from now
he could lose his job
to malik willis but he also if he played
well last year if he played great last
season do the titans take a quarterback
or do they say
let's extend him
and i wonder did ryan tannehill put
himself in this position where the
titans said
we got to start looking down the road
and think about this dan yes
because we're a
you know
a knee jerk reaction we just do that and
tana hill with derrick henry makes his
job easier and i know in the playoff
game henry had finally come back but
when you the last thing we remember is
you throwing three bad picks and losing
well you were the number one seed to a
cincinnati team that was what ten and
seven and they go on and get there yes
all that stuff and then you say well can
ryan tannehill carry us
with his arm if all hell breaks loose
and right now there's that's a major
question and he his job is on the line
and yes dan if they go on let's say they
get to the afc championship game he
plays well but they lose and they'll go
the super bowl they may not have taken a
guy in the third maybe the fifth and
maybe they still take a guy in the third
and extend him because they're building
for the future i don't think tannehill
now he mentioned he was getting therapy
that the scars are going to last forever
of course and his number one job
is to make sure it's like when you're on
a plane dan what's the first thing they
tell you when they when for oxygen if
the mass comes down
you put it on your face and then help
the person next to you in this case in a
football sense it's i got to take care
of my gig if you want to watch like you
you want to watch how i read sports how
i write beforehand how we what time we
get here and then ask questions and i
think ryan tanner will be more than
happy to say sure man here's how you
attack cover two here's what we do on
play action here's how we read it but to
reach out and do it they both have jobs
they both want to start tannehill's
career is on the line after a poor
performance of course he's got his job
first and helping malik willis and
anybody else that plays a different
position willis's job is to learn watch
get better and compete and his job is to
chase down taniel now dan some rookies
will come in and think they know it all
i'm not saying him in any place and they
won't seek out help if that's the case
fine we'll still have a good quarterback
room and we'll still compete and that's
the way it's supposed to be the job
title at quarterback in the nfl isn't
for tom brady to train kyle trask it's
for kyle trask to chase down tom brady
and learn everything you possibly can
sean salsberry former nfl quarterback
also played at usc i'm wondering about
name image and likeness and and i railed
yesterday that
the
educators
chancellors presidents athletic
directors didn't see this coming where
everybody thought it's just going to be
a couple of marquee quarterbacks who are
going to get paid this is about buying a
team this is about being a professional
team and i wonder the biggest negative
for you with name image and likeness as
we move forward is what
well they didn't have it when i played
because i would have made more money
going into sc than i did coming out i
could tell you that
i'd have been born back with two knee
surgeries i made 825 as a rookie i'd
have made 825 in a week as a highly
recruited guy at usc in california now
you know what dan for me it's
isn't this weird how we were talking
about well let's give the guys an extra
sandwich in the refrigerator in the
locker room and then all of a sudden
it turned into like august of what 2020
or 2021 i guess it was where it's like
it went haywire and all that it's out of
control i'm all for guys getting paid i
am the question is how do we
how do we
regulate it to where we're building
dream teams now dan what do we do get to
the point where we sign you to a
four-year scholarship
and then we
then we're going to start trading
players you know what you're going to
leave why don't we trade you for their
backup five-star who wants to get on the
field and he comes start for us or i
want listen we're long
past players and somehow some way with
all the earnings and what they bring
into a program of getting paid for their
jersey sales i get it i'm not big on
hand to hand cash but i'm all for the
players getting paid but where does it
stop now because you mentioned you can
build a dream team what's going to
prevent five guys from going to a an
elite camp and five
seniors saying let's all go here we'll
put our heads together we'll get paid
two million each we'll go to name image
like some of these guys are gonna make
more money than rookies are playing in
the nfl great because everybody says
coaches and athletic directors can leave
and get theirs i'm all for it but where
does it stop it'd be now we can't go
back dan we can't go back
they have to do they have to do a and a
name image and like new salary cap they
do they they actually do with this is
college sports is pro all the way
student athlete needs to be removed
because now some may but we are now
transferring not to play because you
want an opportunity you're transferring
because they're paying you more in a lot
of cases so what stops now when they
flip it if some guy who spent a million
bucks says well after your freshman year
i didn't get an roi i didn't get return
on my investment the the the deal's off
yeah deal then lawsuits and then well
this guy's we're building a dream team
here and you can't go from a set a
ferrari and go back to an amc pacer like
i had in high school so i don't know
where it's going to stop i'm all for him
getting paid but you're exactly right we
are to the point now and then i think
cheating is going to increase dan not
decrease because what's the difference
in an alumni saying here's a million
bucks come speak once a quarter to my
company as opposed to hey you gotta i
don't even know what name is that what
are they endorsing they may be endorsing
it what's the requirement for each
endorsement it's basically becoming
hand-to-hand cash i don't blame the
athlete for wanting it but it's changing
college football as long as well as a
transfer portal and people are going to
start plucking and people are going to
start tampering and it's going to be
constant talk
we do need a salary cap
a salary cap for name image likeness i
don't know how you're going to prevent
this thing it's rolling downhill faster
than i've ever seen yeah i had a source
last night say they're just going to be
more illegal payments because if if
there's a salary cap for name image and
likeness all right we'll give you that
but i'm also going to give you this over
here it's going to continue i'm waiting
for a player to put himself on ebay
and let schools bid on him and as crazy
as that may sound
that's what they're doing they're
they're going to be players who have an
unbelievable year
and then they're going to put themselves
up for auction and just say
you know
you guys interested this is the starting
price and then you start to see guys do
it the the wide receiver at pitt dan
yeah the usc
yeah i'd love to have him at nsc who
doesn't want to go but if you're the
best of the best you say well lincoln
riley's offense they got the number one
recruited quarterback i'm here my guy my
senior left or my junior kenny pickle i
want to go there and plus they're
offering me three million extra bucks
yeah yes you're exactly right they'll
start put that's next like i said this
isn't against the athlete this is about
the adults in the room and how you're
going to put a not a stop to it but
prevent the thing from sliding downhill
great to talk to you as always great
perspective thank you thank you buddy
it's great great to talk to you i
appreciate you dan thank you sean
salisbury former nfl and usc quarterback
our good buddy morning host of the sean
salisbury show sports talk 790 in
houston